we with our creative model over the last
three years have proven actually good
ideas can come from anywhere including
someone who's worked here for seven days
I hate the human behavior that makes
someone feel inferior in all shapes in
life and we definitely need to get that
out of every creative meeting we're in
nothing kills creativity more than a bad
creatively or a bad client that makes
everyone feel like [__] because they put
out their subjective thing and then
somebody in there thinks that their
subjective thing is more better because
of some [__] a war it's all not real
and please don't use not real to not be
nice welcome everybody to the Super Bowl
after party
hey Jim
hi Andrea so good to be here that's a
great reel thanks for putting that
together incredible I know it's it's uh
it's it's a fun it's a it's a great
little snippet of we're gonna be having
conversations with seven CMOS uh that
had ads in the in the Super Bowl we're
really excited to have some rapid fire
discussions with them and we've got oh
Gary's in the house
hi everybody great to see you Jim
great to be here buddy
hi everybody thank you for jumping in I
know everyone's busy given the
incredible crew we have here so thank
you for allocating your time and
attention to this combo
Gary this is the fourth year in a row
we've done this together it's such a
pleasure to do this with you I love it I
look forward to it we have to do it in
person one of these years we really do
we well I think we started we did the
first one person but uh there was a
global pandemic I don't know yeah
um that kind of threw us off but to your
point I think we're kind of back so I
think we should make a commitment right
here right off the bat that this will be
in person uh and so that means everyone
on this call please make sure you're uh
in New York the the first week after the
Super Bowl I mean you've got a year to
plan you know that's the tough part
right like there are real wins and
losses like there's so many great things
that came out of covid so many of our
friends on here right now
are just if we make this Tuesday
February 16th next year in New York are
just not going to be part of this
discussion and we'll be there and so I
think we've got to find our balance but
nonetheless it's great to be here I'm
excited to talk about it so Gary I got
up early on Super Bowl Sunday and I
turned on my TV and I saw you being
interviewed in Glendale early in the
morning with a with a nice turtleneck on
talking about your talking about your
parents which was beautiful but I want
you to tell us about the weekend a bit
what what inspired you what did you do
who what was really remarkable for you I
can definitely tell you that um one of
the
worst strategic decisions of my career
was to wake up at 4am and Arizona to do
that spot
um knowing that TB consumption on cable
is so low right now that I probably have
less people watching that than are
listening to this interview right now
um I don't know if you know this the
desert Arizona is very cold at 5 a.m
yeah yeah really cold and I only had a
T-shirt and then I put the turtleneck
thank God at the last second but
um what you know look I had the fortune
to I see Ian's in here are there some
others you know for me Super Bowl can
why I'm going to Utah tomorrow for
All-Star a a in Orlando
all of it especially in post covid is to
get quality time with quality people I
think when I look at the faces here a
lot of people I know a lot of people I
know super well a lot of people I don't
know that great or I used to know really
well and not as much these days anytime
you can get 15 20 30 minutes of a real
conversation where you can not only talk
about the things off the field family
real life you have that Bond but even if
you can get 10 15 minutes of real talk
right business challenges like this is a
fun combo we get to talk about
creativity
um you know messaging branding and then
there's just the realities of actual
business that everybody here thinks
about which is like the p l and you know
what is the economy structure and so
just what I would say is quality of
conversation and being able to
actually just spend some time and have
Serendipity you know one thing Zoom
doesn't do is allow for Serendipity yeah
so you know the Commissioners uh the
owner's brunch I you know I was
fortunate enough to be in there and just
the incredible level of conversations I
was able to have with Fortune 500
companies and platforms and other
individuals felt like 17 flights worth
of business being done I find these
things to be more efficient than
actually doing the trips one by one and
so I really look forward to it on a
human level yeah Hey listen I I listened
to our conversation last year at this
time and I think the work this year
generally was better I'm not sure where
you are on that but in the in last
year's podcast or recording you were
very vocal that we overuse celebrities
last year and you felt it was lazy on
the part of marketers I kind of felt
celebrities were used a bit differently
this year so I'd like you to are you
still feeling that way after looking at
this body of work well this time one
thing I've been thinking a lot about is
hypocrisy C is at scale in society and
so as the gentleman who had incredible
passion
that celebrities are used too much that
had his Agency use Ben Stiller and Steve
Martin and then have a roast of Mr
Peanut we're going to talk about that
yeah
um look you know my father has a great
saying in Russian that translates to
whoever
signs the check gets to pick the music
right and so you know um look I continue
to believe there's opportunity you think
you think about you know Nicole's a
former Vayner Alum to to see what to be
did I you know I think back to the year
before the QR code I continue to believe
interrupting attention breaking patterns
trying different things is the kissing
cousin to using celebrities that make
you feel something or think something
the clueless recall then still I thought
was and Steve Martin like you know I you
know and then you so like I think
there's a lot of ways to slice it
um I think a lot about I continue to be
overly passionate that everybody on this
call needs to stand up their own mascot
I think we need to bring it back to the
60s and 70s I really believe that so
much more ownable
um you know so yeah I continue to think
that there's better arms than the
celebrity fee
notwithstanding the fact that those
celebrities bring enormous amount of
tension and feelings
there are many people when I think for
example let's talk about Pepsi and I
know Todd's here there's such warm
feelings towards those two individuals
they lack controversy they have an
overall halo effect of like trust and
Goodwill the subconscious of those two
did this I may try this when I see it at
Fountain today or when I'm at 7-Eleven
that's just real psychology that's real
life and that gets into the logic of why
and then you have you know to be
interrupting or like the clueless plague
does that like Nostalgia I think is very
underpriced so I like when we use
celebrities in a recall like that and so
I know there's a lot of ways to hack
human emotion to create consideration
and I think we get to see all those
displayed during Super Bowl which is why
I think we enjoy it especially for the
people here who really think that
branding and marketing is The Ultimate
Sales engine and I would argue almost
all of us on this call believe that to
be true but I think we all can also
agree that when branding and marketing
is done poorly it can be one of the
great wastes of money uh in a business
and so I think that keeps us all up at
night and sharp at night and and I like
that and I like being a part of this
community and I just want to say hi to
everyone
Gary you're a high touch leader you know
the book that you published yesterday
was all about that your team vaynermedia
did three ads for the Super Bowl this
year two on Pepsi one on planners you
know and people are nervous when they do
this work because the Showcase you know
the stage is is really big what did you
say to your team about the work before
it went live
you know I don't know if Robin I know
Nick is here I saw him in the chat now I
see him on my screen is Rob here
um I don't know if Rob's here but I'll
tell you what my team will tell you is
I'm I'm a funny character there's like
three to seven things I'm passionate
about and I'll really put a lot of
energy on that
um emotional happiness and all that is
why I think Vader's doing what it's
doing
um and uh but when it comes to the work
which is so powerful for example let's
just use Rob in this example to this you
you know Todd to give him some roses
while he's on here Todd is an unusual
client that I would argue is similar to
Nick and I where he's an operator who
probably just has naturally better
Talent creatively subjectively than your
average like person it just is what it
is and he has passion for it in a way
that Nick who does client for us who's
on this call and I who am an operator
and a CEO he has passion for it and he's
good at it and so that's a different
kind of clients so for this year for
example what was most exciting to me is
I always have my special relationship
with Todd Nick because he's an account
person that blends into creative in in a
weird way similar to Todd I actually see
them I haven't said this to them but
I'll just do it right here they have so
many similarities they operate but they
have creative skills what was fun about
this year was this was a year that I
felt that Rob our chief creative officer
is now in really in year three of his
journey with us and brings all the years
of what makes Madison Avenue great but I
think now has a sensibility that makes
what's been going on with Vayner happen
and I think this was a year that Rob and
and and Todd really molded together and
built their creative Bond so for me I
didn't say anything my team knows that I
continue to give them Pure Freedom but
would prefer for them to create very
direct business results Direct
calls to action and stand-up mascots we
did not do that and that's okay
um because again back to whoever pays
for the music gets to pick the song
um so I try to influence strategy but I
don't micromanage it especially because
I'm empathetic that these are big ass
bets and and Rafiq and Todd and you know
Nicole like they need to make their
their just and we didn't do the Creative
for two people we're a partner in a
different way but
um we've got to leave them freedom in
this bag I'm still trying to win the
day-to-day commercials battle
Super Bowl takes everyone's intensity to
another place altogether so I try to
tread lightly while inspiring like don't
compromise and completely make it
vanilla because I think we can all agree
and this is scary we can all agree
that there are some Super Bowl
commercials that ran four days ago
that we are not going to be able to
recall here sure your Professionals in
it yep we're professionals in this we're
having a Thursday meeting about it
right we're hanging yeah and and there's
absolutely some commercials that
so were vanilla that we're going to
struggle here and that's how you fall
into don't forget it's seven million
just to get the awareness there's
production there's the agency fee
there's that pocket like you're talking
about a 12 13 14 you know 10 if you got
lucky million dollar Miss and no
business wants that let alone in this
environment
Gary you're a big jets fan so I'm going
to give you the privilege of welcoming
into our conversation the Kansas City
Chiefs CMO Lara Krug world champion
Kansas City Chiefs come on in Lara
welcome
I mean did you know that Elton John's
favorite rapper is Tech Nine
I did not like that see of course thank
you for having me I really appreciate it
but I do know that I'm extremely jealous
of you since I've never been the Jets
have never been to a Super Bowl in my
lifetime and and so you were going to be
part of this because you're in our
incred this is everyone here is part of
this incredible family of like
like-minded individuals but the fact
that you're incredible football team
who's been in wildly consistent at the
top tier over the last five years has
now found themselves a second title must
feel just outrageous huh
honestly outrageous it's a bit surreal
um I think what's the most surreal I've
been here for about Tuesday this is my
second season now obviously having spent
some time in Anheuser-Busch before
um to see the city
I
mean literally grocery stores were
shutting down before the game was played
right like the the that doesn't happen
in most places having grown up in a
couple different places right so to see
the city to see
um I think just the global fandom that
is that has happened over the last few
years
um certainly being on the business side
of it you know there's only so much you
can control right
um and so it's it's pure
um joy and happiness and I think
everyone's just a little bit on I don't
even know Cloud9 Cloud 10 Cloud 11 at
this point
um so we're we're super proud and you
know I think in many ways it is just the
beginning for the dynasty hopefully but
also I think for for fans around the
world who you know may not be like you
Gary and a huge Jets fan like a lot of
people don't have the Loyalty yet to a
team so I feel like we're on our way to
becoming one this is to your point
but this might be very fascinating for a
lot of people this is the globalization
of American football is clearly on right
the Germany execution was great
um London's been going on for a while
obviously I'm trying to strategize my
way to Jets ownership so I have a lot of
relationships and maybe we on this call
can help you Gary maybe we can do that
okay
directly or indirectly Jim
um and I think you know I think what to
your point Lauren I think you know
you're you're hot as an organization
because you know most of my shop you
know I've been watching football for 40
years most of my you know entire life
the Chiefs barely even made the playoffs
and when they did they would have
Heartbreakers like they did in 93 and
things of that nature so you're getting
hot
at the same exact time that American
footballs decided it needs to be Global
because
you know proper football is the MBA is
further along now you're doing this to
your point I would argue the Chiefs
especially how young Patrick is
has disproportionate potential to become
the biggest Global team in the world if
this is a five-year window over the next
five years that adopts a lot of people
in Asia latim and Europe I'm sure you're
thinking about that quite a bit 100 I
mean um I'll say I think that was pretty
much one of the main reasons I was
brought in um people are always shocked
to hear the Chiefs didn't actually have
a formal marketing team before I joined
they've never had a CMO
um and and it's not because they weren't
doing an amazing job they were clearly
doing an amazing job but the change has
started to happen where the fandom is
not only in Kansas City right now it it
it's actually fascinating we're one of
the most displaced teams in the NFL 32
and yet we have the highest avidity of
fandom and so to your point Gary I mean
with us playing in Germany next year
it's definitely our Focus trying to find
the right way to connect the game The
Players
um our heritage obviously with the hunt
family how do you do that in a world
where not everyone can come to the
stadium right even if we built 12
stadiums on top of each other it's not
going to be hundreds of millions of
people that obviously many of the
partners on here right are advertising
on so it's a huge focus of ours and and
we're just trying to capitalize on it
right now because it is the window if we
don't do it now it will be passed right
now that's right that's right Laura from
Sunday morning until today what's been
the most memorable part of this
experience
oh that's a hard one
um uh you know I actually will say I
think um I think post game I mean po I
mean the win was obviously my post the
win though and having our organization
come together
having the players and and ownership and
the business staff and everyone that
works really really hard that doesn't
necessarily get all the credit right
getting us all together to celebrate it
is a pretty extraordinary thing
um and then yesterday you know riding on
buses and watching an entire city
literally shut down to celebrate a sport
right it's remarkable so I don't know if
I could pick one but I would say those
two
that's good well listen uh I want you to
we're going to bring Deb wall from GM
into the conversation and they just did
an amazing amount of creative work in
this game and Laura I'd like you to
welcome Deb in and maybe have the first
question for her oh welcome Dad very
nice to meet you
um thank you uh Gary and Jim for having
us all together
um so I guess one question I have for
you is so I remember
um being on the other side
um and the ad meter comes out and it's
everyone's kind of focus and favorite
point of attention for you what was the
thing on Monday morning or at least on
late on Sunday night that you felt like
this was going to be successful or not
or and how did you judge that internally
thank you Laura and hi everyone it's
great to hear your point of view on
everything because I think it's really
interesting as we all think what
platforms like Super Bowl mean for the
future
um since they're one there aren't that
many anymore that draw 113 million
people
um so my most uh important thing was
actually Motley Fool which came out and
said that you know we had done our
earnings announcement on the 31st we
started showing our first spot on the
February 2nd and we had a great um year
thanks to all the work of all the team
members at GM so our stock price went up
which was great and then when we
launched the Netflix partnership
um investors acknowledge that this is a
different way to start thinking about
doing marketing Investments and brand
Partnerships overall so our stock went
up again and they gave us credit for
another six percent which was great and
then of course the Jim Stengel which I
call the true ad meter because as we as
we all know admeter is
quite something anyways I won't say
anything more about that but I mean how
many people actually rate 51 some spots
and do it so what kind of fidelity do
you have on that Deb we have some things
in common you know I once did an ad with
Will Ferrell
we did it with Old Spice and Semi-Pro
tie up and we shot about 35 ads with him
and we never gave him a script
so I'd like you to talk a little bit
about Will Ferrell and your team was he
scripted or was that him being will you
know will always gets some ideas but
it's will being will he's he's amazing
and he is amazing I think one of the
best talents I've ever worked with
um and he always comes through something
more but most genuinely if you remember
like we we used will two years ago when
we issued the first challenge
um versus Norway yeah and that was
something he was completely honestly and
authentically engaged with so when we
had this opportunity to come back and
and take it to the next level about all
right how do you normalize the idea of
EVS for America and especially worldwide
definitely but especially in the U.S he
was amazing on that part and I like that
I think continuity and consistency
um with when you use celebrities really
important and I have just so much
respect for him he also was amazing he
came internally he became a contract
employee and you know went and
participated in our Yammer discussions
and Yammer pages he shot the most
hilarious video showing his Hummer EV
and um you know said thank you to all of
our employees in the plant to actually
build the cars and you know it just kind
of brings the whole importance of
something like a platform like Super
Bowl how important it is on so many
levels
I love what you do about making a
statement about your strategy and your
culture on the Super Bowl and I think
that's such a smart strategy internally
and externally could you talk a bit more
about that Deb
um yeah I think it's right now when
there's so much transformation going on
that's what makes a difference and again
for us this was really interesting we
didn't just do a one product shot we
were trying to Showcase a different
relationship with Netflix which is the
largest content producer and by the way
they were awesome to work with I really
appreciate their team a lot of
creativity a lot of real Focus they are
the largest streamer they truly impact
culture
um and I think as we all look in the
future you know we all know ads are how
effective are ads it's how do we use all
these other channels and and ways of
getting our messages across so that's
why I was especially interested now the
other thing I would share with everyone
it's a lot of work to do like a big
partnership like that it took us a lot
this was not something we cooked up in
the last you know six months it takes a
lot of extra work to do something that
appears like that so
um I think that's important for everyone
to know and then we see it as a platform
that can continue on and on because we
have GM energy we have sustainability in
common we have all these things that
apart from any AD relationships that we
do with Netflix which this does allow us
to also be a first mover in that
partnership
is really important and I think that's
the ways we think about Marketing in the
future
I really wanted to do this and the team
did because I think that signifies where
we should go as an industry and how we
should start thinking about things
differently and even you know again you
know we debate every year should we
really invest all this money in Super
Bowl and I'm really worried because
there aren't that many platforms that
gather a lot of people anymore
collectively and that's important for
humans you know we we want that common
experience but how are we going to
achieve that in a couple more years
um so I think that's why we should it's
important to experiment and really look
at different ways of doing that Gary
anything for Deb before we let her go
the the last couple things she just
really got me going
one to her point and I think you know
social digital guy but I've been beating
the drum of Super Bowl's underpriced for
a decade and like and agree with dab
like
um I you know just very honestly I would
continue to spend as much as I could if
I had one of these roles on Super Bowl
because I think actualized consumption
actualized consumed reach versus
potential reach are two very different
things so I think her point is
absolutely right there and then just
because how my brain works when she
talked about the importance of us having
these Collective moments it makes a lot
of sense given the last decade of what
we've dealt with but recency bias is
something I'm thinking a lot about and
where my brain went was before
television and radio we didn't have that
and what did that actually mean and so I
got a little bit weird about like
thinking about the 1800s for a second so
before that took me personally but you
know I'm not sure if that's relevant for
this so I think we should move on but
Deb congrats on everything you know I
know we get to jam a little bit here on
our LinkedIn chats and things of that
nature but I continue to really root for
you and I really do appreciate some of
the different things that you spear
ahead and I think it's important for the
industry thanks you guys it's great to
see everybody Deb we're going to bring
in another CMO who knows a little bit
about entertainment we have Todd Kaplan
CMO Pepsi who's going to join the
conversation and Deb I'm going to let
you ask the first question to Todd GM to
Pepsi here we go yeah well I was
watching with interest as you changed
your attack from you know sponsoring the
halftime show to really in a really
great presence with storytelling that
was continuous so how do you feel about
that and what's your thought about Super
Bowls in the future
yeah I I feel great about it at the end
of the day
um I think to your point there's no
other platform like it where you get
over 100 million people all together
talking about the same thing going on
the ups and downs and all of that and I
think the the whole idea of Super Bowl
is kind of what you do with those
moments and how you capitalize on that
is more than just eyeballs right and
that's where all the storytelling of the
before and all the pr all the after all
the during and the social commentary and
all that and I think we made a strategic
shift to move away from the halftime
show
um and again it was 10 years for us and
I think it was time for us to kind of
Turn the Page and move on to what's next
and we're feeling great about that and
this year you know we had a really uh it
was a different brief because it was
very um product focused really we had
reformulated our Pepsi Zero sugar
formula and
um we really had a goal of trial and uh
it's an interesting brief for something
like Super Bowl trying to get someone to
try your product and especially when as
we were just talking about early on
there's this healthy uh there's a really
sharp inside of that is there's a
healthy distrust that consumers have of
advertising in general of why the hell
should I believe this person I paid them
money they're only saying that because I
paid them to say that and um that that
offense is done the worst on Super Bowl
Sunday so we said what if we lean into
that tension and bring you know two
beloved actors Steve Martin Ben Stiller
together to kind of play this little is
it real or is it acting game with
everybody and have them the big punch
line is they try the product like wow
that's really good or is it I don't know
you try it yourself you know um and uh
we put our money where our mouth is and
we also gave out online over 10 million
sample up to 10 million samples of the
product to make sure people actually
couldn't try it and we were really happy
with the results obviously it was a big
shift for us coming from you know the
halftime show and the amount of
discussion that that drives but even
with that you know we still drove a ton
of share and voice um you know Kim from
my team is on here and a number of other
folks from the Vayner crew uh had a war
room over at Twitter where we continued
to drive a lot of social conversation
and dialogue and uh really showed that
you know with some spots in the game
some Billboards some clever online stuff
you could still drive you know a lot of
share of voices one of the most talked
about uh Brands as well as you know we
still got almost up to 30 billion uh
earned media Impressions out of it from
the pr pre-enduring and it's also going
to be launching a new campaign we'll be
talking about in uh in another week or
so with some more beats that'll come
also so we're feeling great about it so
Todd if you look out three months from
now what will you say if will this be
effective if what happens what higher
trial
yeah I think for us the the proof is in
the pudding with uh this is a critical
product and category for us to grow and
um literally just getting it in people's
mouths uh the reformulation we have it's
um it's an advantage product we know
it's better than our competitors and we
just need to get in people's hands so uh
that's going to be a big push and just
continuing to kind of drive that uh
awareness of that we have a zero sugar
product as well I want to talk to Todd
for a moment about creativity Gary uh
I've I've tweeted that PepsiCo may be
the best company to consistently produce
Super Bowl level quality work
and the work on PopCorners and Doritos
this year was just terrific so Todd if
you could put your big corporate hat on
what is it about this culture that just
consistently delivers this kind of
creativity it's um it's something where
you know and and listen there's a the
benefit of we have these big brands in
this household penetration in these
products right so the game we're playing
on some is a little bit different so
look at pop corners versus Pepsi even
back years ago when I launched bubbly
and it was about driving awareness what
is this new product so the brief's going
to change every year if you're trying to
drive awareness Affinity Equity all the
you know trial whatever it ends up being
but I think um you know knowing kind of
the scale and the power of um you know
how to tap into consumers and knowing
that we don't sell direct to Consumer we
need to really maintain more than just
top of Mind awareness we need to really
get that emotional connection and get
people talking about our Brands and more
um Into The Ether and I think um a lot
of the models that we've kind of built
to PepsiCo have few old some really kind
of creative and out of the box thinking
you know it's kind of funny I was doing
some talking to someone the other day
and as we were talking about the ad
meter and we were debating how horrible
the metrics are with that and all that
stuff but we were looking up some of the
past that um you know Pepsi has four of
the top five rated ad meter spots of all
time and actually there was a survey
that shows were the most associated
brand of all brands with the Super Bowl
when you think of 40 years back of
advertising the halftime show all of
that and so there's a big also internal
I think pride and kind of legacy of
wanting to you know we have a little bit
of a competitive fire between us and
Frito on the beverage and snack side and
and wanted to continue to push forward
and the Doritos and PopCorners folks did
a great job this year as well but um I
think it's just um you know continuing
to push forward and and think of these
Brands and how you can tap into the fact
that there's all these cultural truths
and how you can kind of turn them and
play with them in your creative process
is really um you know how we get it done
Gary your team works with Pepsi do you
want to comment on that add to that
about the what's special about this
culture yeah I think I put in the chat
I'm also noticing a lot of people are
not part of the chat all the good stuff
is going on in the chat along with me
and Jim trying to as always please get
in there because I think you know this
is going to end in 30 minutes I think
for a lot of people if you're just
consuming it and not participating I
think that
renders The Experience not as strong uh
I said in the chat I think pop culture
actually matters to PepsiCo but look
they have Youth products there's some
reasons why that makes sense but I think
it does and I do think that
brands that may skew a little older also
can win on pop culture that is relevant
to the audience they're trying to reach
and so I I believe it's in the DNA in
the Halls you see it consistently and I
think that it the ideation starts so I
under the hood I'm very aware of the
other ideas that were being debated and
I can tell you all of them were grounded
in all sorts of layers of popular
culture and I think you know Vayner has
been thinking a lot lately about why
we're over indexing with our social work
and our above the line work to the
business result and a lot of it sits in
what Peter Chun who's here does on
platform and a lot sits on Wanda and Rob
and strategy and and creative it's we're
obsessed with this concept of pack we
call it platform and culture and so I
think Pepsi is dominating on culture
time and time again and I think platform
is do you on understand the distribution
do you understand like what the did you
understand the uh the assignment Super
Bowl's got 30 second video or so
obviously sometimes 45 sometimes 60. and
then obviously that plays out
dramatically in other platforms rafik
did you know Mr Peanut did the
assignment there but then also extended
the assignment to 2B and executed very
different creative there that looks like
actual production of a thing not a
commercial and so I think everyone in
this room because I'm always obsessed
with why did people allocate time here
so if you leave with anything this
acronym of like pack the platform and
the current state of the culture of your
consumer if you can synthesize that to
being contextually relevant to your
distribution in an emerging streaming
World which is going to eat up most of
television as we know it and in Social
which has all the rest of the attention
but it also plays out to activations it
to Billboards to raise video to Spotify
so I think on the culture side which we
think is the one of the two pillars that
dominates success I think it's just in
their DNA I think just just to add one
last thing before you move on to I would
also say is the um aside from the
cultural truths it's the commitment to
the craft I would say of how we partner
with our our agencies and people who get
us there whether it's our in-house
people who do stuff out of Dallas and
Plano where as you were talking about
how we worked with Robin team um you
know we get under the hood into the
creative craft of it all versus you know
sit at our seat and just buy ideas from
people and so I think that's a uh the
executions you know uh the difference
that sometimes makes a difference in
some of this work that somebody have a
great idea that isn't executed the right
way and all that kind of stuff and so we
we really blur those lines
Mr Peanut come into this conversation
with Mr Pepsi Rafiq lewandi had a
marketing for Planters join our
conversation I I hope you guys are
friends I mean peanuts and Pepsi I mean
it's perfect
that's it we need to work on that yes I
mean I gotta Todd I share a lot of what
you said that we obviously spent 10
years of my career at PepsiCo and I I
would say it's the pride in our in the
brands and pepsicle Brands and it's the
care that you know starts from
leadership at the very top to the bottom
like it's just depreciation for creative
and appreciation for kind of just being
part of culture which a lot of times you
take for granted but they're actually
not present across you know all
companies so fully agree with you there
right Rafiq you have had a long-term
commitment to the Super Bowl and you
know I and I think it was an unexpected
brand to come to the Super Bowl a few
years ago so would you speak to why this
has worked for you so well and is it a
tough sell internally to be involved
year in and year out
we haven't asked that question once so
far so that's how successful it has been
I fully agree with Gary at this point in
time this is the biggest moment for
storytelling this is the biggest moment
for engagement and inviting consumers to
also participate in telling your story
and so that's what we've been doing
consistently and kind of particularly
since the moment we kind of killed Mr
Peanut and locked all that love and kind
of moment for him and culture we've been
on a roll and frankly what I also love
about Super Bowl is like every year you
kind of have to see where the culture is
going and where your brand you know
needs to achieve and then find that you
know crazy connection between them so
you know one year we didn't even part be
part of Super Bowl officially but we
actually were because we donated our
money to you know little acts of
extraordinary substance on you know
during covert time last year we played
the whole game around you know one
another you know for all months at a
time and you know into mixed nuts and it
was the first time we actually moved
away from Mr Peanut and really focused
on snacking and then this year we got
him back again and because it is time
for peanuts it is a recessionary Time
peanuts are an amazing snack that are
very much underrated and so honestly
Super Bowl has worked so well for us
um you know year on year obviously in
partnership with the Vayner has been
incredible as well and every year I
think we are just continuing to raise
the bar
how do you judge success Rafiq is it
volume share conversations discussion
what is it definitely uh our presence in
store and share and that has been
improving I would say year one when we
kind of killed Mr Peanut we were almost
did not even plan for anything in store
this year we kind of have you know way
more planned ahead we have Walmart for
the first time supporting us and giving
us a lot of space and store so we
actually are you know increasingly doing
better in execution in store which is
driving our success and then obviously
you know Impressions and engagement from
consumers and uh that's you know so far
again we're doing really well there
I loved your concept this year by the
way for the Vayner team and you're made
to be roasted I mean it's so perfect
it's so obvious it's so creative and the
way you executed it just was so much fun
so could you talk a little bit about the
origin of the concept we're always
looking to get you know original
Concepts and marketing concepts that
will break through we do concept testing
all the time talk about that concept
that I remember the brief the brief in
the Tweet was like enjoy the peanuts
um and and if you think about that's as
simple as that and I think coming out of
and and and everyone wonders why
agencies are all driving themselves
crazy
talk about having a lot of room in that
brief right yeah yeah you know I I
started to jump in repeat but just a
point that I've been meaning a lot about
the brief is really fun because that's a
dream because Rob prefers that Rob's
team prefers that that means they can do
whatever the hell they want
I on the other hand like from a
day-to-day standpoint take Super Bowl
out think that a lot of the brands here
again trying to bring value to this call
in a different way getting briefs that
have a ton of teeth in them from a
day-to-day marketing standpoint is
something that we need to add to our
infrastructure especially with social as
every brand here goes to a model of
doing social marketing on a daily basis
because how much brand is being built
there more and more briefs with like
very narrow
like consumer segmentations or like very
sharp tight very narrow briefs will
really help because I think it helps on
relevance but for Super Bowl that wide
of a brief is like a creative's dream
but sometimes puts you into a swirl
I want to bring it Dana Marino sorry
let's bring in Dana Marino of rakitan
into the conversation and Rafiq I'll let
you welcome her and maybe have a
question for Dana who has been in the
Super Bowl now two years in a row
correct so we'll talk about that in a
moment but Refuge back to you to bring
Dane in with a question
yeah no so then we've been obviously
parking on the creative side as well
um so excited to to see you again this
year so tell us what what was your most
exciting moment for for this week as you
prepped for Super Bowl oh my gosh nice
to see you overfeak and of course both
of you my most exciting moment was
coming into this office on Monday and
just the Elation of everyone in the
company from the people who actually
worked on the Super Bowl ad and The
Campaign which I think you guys know we
have an in-house brand and creative team
we don't have an agency to the engineers
to member supports to everyone in the
company just that pride and the Press
coverage that um was just truly stunning
for the last couple weeks on the rackete
and Clovis campaign people just you can
feel in their bones the excitement and
the pride for the company that was
definitely my best moment
Dana you had you had Hannah last year
Hannah waddingham of tidala so and you
felt really good about the ROI last year
you thought it was really productive
this year you had Alicia Silverstone of
Clueless brilliant tie-in by the way how
do you feel I know it's early but how do
you feel about the impact this year the
ROI this year of your effort yeah I love
all the questions about is the Super
Bowl worth it because I do feel
passionately about that and you know we
do watch of course what happens that day
and I will say to your question yes app
downloads are up shopping is up sign ups
you know signups are up search volume is
up all those indicators that we feel
great about that one day but truly
that's not why we do the Super Bowl to
your point about Hannah what we look at
is the year-long results of what happens
over the year and things like our brand
awareness number went up four points and
every one of you on this call knows how
hard it is to move even half a point
right bracketon is not a household name
in the U.S quite yet it is of course an
Asian so we're really working on that
Brandon winner so Four Points year on
year that's a big deal and we had you
know I talked to Jim last week about
this we had 10 percent lift in our
buyers over the year and so many metrics
like that that tell us yes the Super
Bowl is worth it yes that day we look at
those numbers but it's really the year
long effort that we prove we belong here
I know you feel one benefit of the Super
Bowl is the impact in your culture
inside the pride the buzz you just
talked about that when you came in on
Monday morning so could you say a bit
more about why that is so important for
you and how you leverage that
yeah well I mean part of the pride is
the in-house Team part part of that is
being able to do something like the
Super Bowl all on the inside of our own
house there is an incredible feeling
that comes with but you know I think all
of us can relate to how hard it's been
to get employees back to the office and
there you know that has been a true
struggle of ours you know across the
board leaders everywhere of all kinds
thinking about that and I will say the
more we're together the more prideful we
feel the more we think about it and when
we do big milestone moments like the
Super Bowl and other big campaigns like
this it helps people want to be part of
the culture and want to be with their
teammates and want to be in the office
and so that's part of you know we with
an in-house team you know trying to keep
these creatives as you guys all know
motivated and inspired and working on
cool stuff and the Super Bowl of course
is one of those things and just getting
people together to celebrate like this
has been really impactful on our culture
Barry over to you anything for Dana
you know what what is the biggest fear
when you go into this kind of bet from
your standpoint I see some questions
about measurability there's a lot of
people here you Tinder I think Melissa
jumped on it as well like you know again
I I come from a lens of I'm a
businessman who happens to be infatuated
and enjoys marketing and branding
because I think it's the best way to
build an actual business what about what
about the flip side of all this Nirvana
and us all hanging out and enjoying this
combo like in an organization that's you
know a real company uh there there's
going to be CFOs there's going to be
CEOs there's going to be board members
there's gonna be people that are saying
prove it like cool you measured it
throughout the year but what about the
end caps at this or what about that
business but like where does it where
does the rubber hit the road for you and
anybody else in the chat because I know
that seems to be the tone and tenor of
some of the combo in a different Lane I
mean I it's a great question and this
sort of age-old debate about the Super
Bowl and is it worth it and I think it
depends on the company it depends on
where your company is in it it's life
stage I think it depends on what you
need to do within the region like in
this U.S region we need to build
awareness and understanding of racketon
right that we have a lot of people who
have heard our name because they see us
on the Golden State Warriors jersey or
they know us you know from the Barcelona
jersey in Europe or Japan you know
whatever it is but they don't know what
racketon is right so I think it depends
I mean Pepsi has a totally different
um strategy than we do right as relates
to culture and the Super Bowl we need
people to become aware and understand
how meaningful rakitin can be and so
you're right we do look at those metrics
you know the week before the day of the
week after over the year the next
quarter I mean we look at the science I
assure you it's just we have multiple
layers by which we measure success some
of which of course is what happens that
day on our site and in our app and what
happens over the year as we're trying to
build the engagement and build the
awareness so Dana stay with us for a
minute we're going to bring in Nicole
Carla piano from Tubi hey Nicole Welcome
to the conversation a couple days after
your Super Bowl spot aired there was in
the news that fox got an offer of over
two billion dollars for Toby
so you obviously had a very high Roi if
that's if there's any correlation in
that but I thought it came out before I
think at the end I did it really in
anticipation of the Super Bowl I think
we'd be at like four or five now for an
offer after Super Bowl but we'll have to
ask Lachlan but that was before yeah
well I thought your efforts this year
were so amazing so Dana what did you
think about 2B this year I
I asked you Nicole because we had a long
debate when we were looking at Concepts
about stunt type object please I'm dying
to know sort of how hard was that to get
approved you know through you through
your team members through your
Executives because that is a very
specific strategy and of course you had
another spot of course but the stunt
type object is a bold move so tell us I
would love to hear about that I can tell
you the back story which is very
interesting but
um Mischief came up with this idea of
hacking the interface and we thought
about hacking a generic car ad because
people watch the ads so intensely and I
just didn't you know I'm new to this
organization I started in August I
didn't know the kind of room I'm walking
into what the Creative Energy was going
to be so we presented rabbit holes we
talked about it and um it was actually
with Lachlan and he was like I feel like
nobody knows the product and people need
to see the product and I was like well
we actually we have this kind of edgy
thing that I just kind of soft pitched
it and um Fox Sports was in the meeting
and they're like hack the game
like you can hack the broadcast and
that's amazing I can what and so it's
different because
you know Fox is you know hosting the
Super Bowl we can make things like that
as an organization happen and so it was
really just luck and evolution and
actually having a construct of an idea
not even imagining that they would even
let me do that and then it just kind of
free-flowing in the conversation and a
big partnership with the you know CMO
Fox Sports Robert Gottlieb because he
was like we have to make this authentic
how would we do it like how would it
look real and so um they really leaned
in and helped execute that
you have all this momentum now all this
Buzz all this attention
what where do you go from here how do
you build on this most amazing momentum
so many people have challenges like that
right yeah and I just um I think
everyone else in the room had done this
before this is my first time and I think
I haven't even had a chance to enjoy it
because I'm just like how do I follow on
this like what's next how do we keep
that momentum
um not that I'm not proud and there's a
moment to be proud and my team got me a
Super Bowl dupe ring but um I just think
how do you the bar is set and how do you
keep doing it year after year I think it
was my first year we had very
you know specific constraints on budget
on timelines we don't pay for commercial
time you don't know when your spots are
going to air it's kind of like the wild
west at Fox three days before so you
have to create a lot of things and
things are going to change last minute
and you have to be flexible the spots
moved the amount of time we got moved so
um so I think that I just wonder uh like
how do you continue and what it feels
like your second time because your first
time I think that the expectation is
like oh we're gonna do this thing and we
hope it's good but it's not like always
comparing to yourself right your own
benchmarks which I think is is a
challenge going forward right
I did so much interruptive work a few
years ago when they took over the Super
Bowl this kind of reminded me of that
that kind of the impact that you had
just everyone was talking about it and
when you did the Takeover of the screen
our house went nuts it was all this
screaming all over the house because we
had a couple TVs on we had a lot of
young kids over all this screaming and
that was it was so good so congrats well
done I'm lucky in the sense that the
game was the Kansas City Chiefs and the
Eagles it was so close I mean that spot
moved a million times when they moved me
to Q4 I was like no this is going to be
terrible and it was like it actually
built to it yeah quarter four is
scary like you know everyone's too young
for this
um but boy oh boy the 80s the mid 80s to
mid 90s was a disaster every game was a
blowout and quarter three and four was
just like death and you know luckily the
parody of the NFL now I think really
helps us as marketers where most games
are still going to be fairly close in
third and fourth but fourth quarter
still you know that I remember was it
the Michael B Jordan Amazon ad with the
Chiefs you know Tampa game which got a
little bit out of hand towards the end I
remember thinking that was a really
strong potential ad that like really
never caught it though if it was in the
first quarter I felt would have had a
lot more juice and so that talk about
like timing and I think you know the
tide hack Jim and I know Nick worked on
that when he was at another agency like
there were some really good stuff going
on with that but that's commercial
within commercial yeah back to what
Nicole's saying which is like the the
Serendipity of just speaking out loud
this is a that's a big learning for what
I just took away from Nicole is too many
people here sit even at this level sit
on ideas and just let them pass which is
like one of like the amount of really
not great thought starters that come out
of my mouth in meetings is like a lot
but it's because I lack God shaking his
head yes there yeah it's because I lack
the fear I lack the fear that it's you
know that's fine even sometimes by the
time it's out of my mouth I'm like I
didn't even like that my darn self but
that might make Sam M who's on here say
but yes but like we do not have an and
and lack of fear culture and marketing
that we have in other parts of the
business universe that I play in and I
think again trying to think of themes
for everyone to walk away from if
anything if Nicole and I know her very
well because we spent a lot of time
together if she wasn't who she was and
didn't have the ability to do that then
what happened happened Sunday doesn't
happen I think a lot of people here even
at the level they are today
sometimes in the midst of a the thing
that I've always struggled with with
creative agencies is they use
subconscious
or conscious behaviors towards their
clients to impose their creative
subjectivity as if there's so much more
creative you know back to the top thing
I mentioned and I think everyone here
even if you were you know some of the
CMOS here came up the analytics track
and have just decided that they're not
as creative as like the fancy characters
on the other side of their table and I
think that's completely wrong I think
that we with our creative model over the
last three years to Rob back to his
journey have proven actually good ideas
can come from anywhere including someone
who's worked here for seven days versus
a creative director at four fancy shops
that's a big transformation and I think
if anybody if you want to leave with
something out of this we need to talk
more in these meetings because our
talking may not be the good thing it
just might be the seed of a great thing
that somebody else picks up on and back
to everyone being leaders here we must
eliminate fear eye rolling like this I
hate the human behavior that makes
someone feel inferior in all shapes in
life and we definitely need to get that
out of every creative meeting we're in
because it nothing kills creativity more
than a douchebag creative lead or a
douchebag client that makes everyone
feel like [__] because they put out
their subjective thing and then somebody
in there thinks that their subjective
thing is more better because of some
[__] award ad meter ad week uh can
lion it's all not real and please don't
use not real to not be nice mm-hmm
Andrea Sullivan the CMO vaynermedia and
one of my favorite people would you join
us now and I think you're going to close
us out with some hot takes Nicole
congrats what an amazing amazing effort
but Andrea back to you to sort of close
us out with a few hot takes we got some
great folks in the audience that I we
thought we might we might bring up and
ask them what their hot takes were from
the game so can we bring up Ian
trombetta from the NFL
yeah great work well done Ian wow busy
couple weeks it's great to be here
Ian we'd love to hear from you a little
bit about everybody's talking about the
halftime show yeah it was uh it was
great
um Rihanna was fantastic obviously new
partner with apple music so there was
quite a bit to get on board with them I
thought they did a really nice job a lot
to live up to with Pepsi in the last
several years so they did a great job
and the obviously Rihanna being pregnant
uh which we learned at least I learned
very late in the week during rehearsals
that was such a a huge moment
um you know for for us as well as for
for her and the audience at home
um a couple things that I just like to
touch on if you don't mind just
listening to the conversation
um you know the Super Bowl it's actually
bigger than I think many people actually
know uh it's actually bigger than the
113 million people that Nielsen rates
what happens is they're measuring that
off of an average household uh that's
that's watching TV on a normal basis but
if you take the Super Bowl which we've
actually worked on some custom analysis
with them it's well over 200 million
that are actually watching the Super
Bowl live and such a powerful moment on
social as well it's the most powerful
moment on social of the Year hands down
so whichever way you're looking at it
through linear or through social and
obviously you should all be thinking
about it just in terms of the surround
sound on the day of but also the week
leading into it there are so many great
moments and hype building up into the
Super Bowl starting with opening night
and I think you know Laura who was on
earlier Jen at the eagles they both did
a terrific job of Leaning into that
moment when the teams arrived so really
when that happens the hype machine is
starting and and nothing really else is
is really invading the culture other
than the Super Bowl conversation and
that build up to the actual game itself
so lots of I think great momentum
heading into next year in Las Vegas and
you know Gary you you'd mentioned the
international growth and that's
something I'd love to talk about maybe
maybe that at another time but that is a
major Focus for us as well so super
exciting and obviously great results for
for hopefully everyone here thank you
Ian congrats we want to bring up Andrea
zaretsky next from E-Trade
Hi how are you
fantastic Andrew you've been e-trade's
been on the Super Bowl off and on for 15
years so I love it want to hear this hot
take for sure yeah sure
um so you know this first of all it's
great to be here and I loved the work
this year I thought it was incredible I
think in addition to all the levity I
think emotion was on the field this year
the two dog commercials I think really
captured everyone's Hearts you know
sometimes we hope it's babies but uh
dogs I think did a really good job Faith
was on the field I thought that was a
new one with the two commercials that
got a lot of talk but I agree with you I
think everyone's being a lot more
holistic and thinking through their
whole strategy to make the most of
pregame day of and after the game I'm
seeing that from all the brands and I
think that really helps with the
investment in all the conversations you
were having about Roi
how do you continue the momentum I think
that's the name of the game jump in here
I also just want to say it I agree
E-Trade baby I do think is truly top 10
all time
um I think we can all agree with that
agree but I just want to thank everybody
I really hence why I'm jumping off I
have to go to a five o'clock that's a
little bit of a important fire but just
knowing how busy everybody is that all
of you continue to show up to these and
I'll leave you with the thing that
matters to me the most you need to hire
people for your teams I think we've
groomed some of the most contemporary
best talent in the world that played out
today with Nicole on here
um if there's anything I can help you
with you need me to take a selfie with
your nephew whatever you need just reach
out and uh I'll let you all continue
here and I'll see you all soon see you
Gary thank you Gary
foreign
[Music]